hi there Steve Kaufman here I want to
most of you know me as a person who gets
on YouTube here and talks about input
based language learning
occasionally talks about politics I'd
like to do more of that but I have
another life I'm involved in the wood
business I'm one of the shareholders in
a sawmill in northern Alberta last week
with my wife we went there for our
annual Christmas party dance party with
the employees and it was also the 20th
anniversary of the founding of the mill
manís located in the Peace River region
which straddles Alberta and BC it's a
rich region of farmland it's very far
north for being an agricultural area
there's oil and gas up there there's and
forests there's been a lot of change
there's a shortage of Labor in Alberta
generally as a result now at the mill
and the little town of Manning of 1,000
people there are maybe a hundred
Filipinos ten or fifteen or twenty of
them work at the mill and so it's quite
a mixture of people the area was settled
initially by I mean the the natives have
lived there for thousands of years in
the cold in the winter at least and it
was settled by people from Europe
British Ukrainian French German you name
it so you'll notice in these videos that
I'll show you that we have quite a
mixture of people natives Filipino
European origin people you'll see the
party you'll see the food cooked up by
the Ukrainian ladies pierogies and such
and since there's a significant
Ukrainian group and polish origin people
that people like to make fun of
themselves so you'll see we have a
comedian who is one of the people from
the town who put on her Ukrainian
costume and made fun of pretended to
speak with a Ukrainian accent during our
safety presentations where we give you
know workers who have worked safely for
20 years or 10 or 15 years various
prizes so have a look at this and I'll
have a few comments to say at the end
thanks for listening
but don't go away because I'm gonna come
on at the end after you see this medley
of videos that I've taken with my iPhone
okay well I hope you can hear on there
here we are in northern Alberta near
Manning Alberta today is quite warm
what's the temperature today ray about
20 minus 20 Celsius yesterday we were
like 30 to 32 the coldest in the world
the day I mean it was warm it was it
warmed up a bit early and today was 3839
with a wind no heard now without the
wind we're like 50 with the wind sorry
yeah so and so we decided that the
coldest day the coldest place in the
world we're going snowshoeing so
yesterday we went and it was cold but
today is like minus 20 it's warm really
today so we don't expect to meet up with
any bears dear maybe yes maybe a moose
an idea
yeah but we're ready for it and that
with that we will continue and tonight
is the 20th anniversary party of Manning
diversified porters products rail runs
the place and we are building and
expanding and particularly getting into
energy so that there isn't a sliver of
word of wood that doesn't get you life
because this one here is renewable right
although we don't saw this kind of stuff
and you'll notice that MDF the MVP and
Richard our cameraman is MV MP that's
who we are
thank you
the food here
so to complete this game you must move
the ball by moving your head the way you
wish and the ball must do the Vaseline
for three seconds to be to be that's
like that's like envy Fe get account we
would like some more Vaseline
all right I'm talking to one of the
local residents here advantage would you
bulla Phi as a local resident yes 20
years 20 years and aside for working at
the mill you are a utter yes you hunt
animals you killed you're a killer a
hundred years and we killed as well all
right but you eat everything you yes and
what do you want for bear yeah yeah yeah
yeah and you're also telling me that to
supplement your carnivorous diet you eat
berries what kind of berries and
mushrooms yep I'm here
Oh mushroom said morels are huge shaggy
made much as that berries the right time
of year
wild raspberries cranberries rose hips
rose hips
Hans cloudberries seniors
we're doing it this is gonna go viral on
my youtube channel this is the lovely
Cecilia do you approve of al-khaliq
animals there you have it I hope you
enjoyed it if you have any questions
about Manning or the forest industry
please send me a note and the next time
I post it will probably be on language
learning bye for now